welcome I am adore Chun I'm a partner at
Y Combinator and I am here interviewing
Craig Kenan how's it going good
how are you doing I'm doing very well
great thanks for being here and for
being on your own podcast no problem I
had a great time setting in a lot and so
Craig is the head of marketing at Y
Combinator and also the extraordinaire
host of this great Y Combinator podcast
and he actually asked me a few weeks ago
on topics I was interested in and doing
on a podcast so I thought about things I
want to learn more about and one of
those things is actually podcasting
itself it's hitting its stride I think
and who better to ask than someone like
yourself so I want spend most of the
time talking about podcasting trends
what you think about it how to do it
correctly things like that and about the
Y Combinator podcast itself but maybe
can start off with telling us you know
people people lots of people listen to
you you know what two to three times a
week know anything about you so why
don't you start off with whose Creek
cannon where are you from you know how
did you what's your background how did
you how did you learn about YC and how
did you even end up here yeah that's
that's a big question
I'll do the quick version so yeah hi my
name is Craig I'm from Boston or near
Boston I went to school at NYU and I was
an English major so I was like the guy
all you people all you CS engineers made
fun of and I was about to graduate and I
realized that I was like moderately
unemployable I didn't have very many
skills but I was running the comedy
magazine at NYU and so I was like well
maybe I can get a job at this place
called the onion and so I just sent out
an application and like that was the one
thing I got so started working there and
while I was there I actually started
reading hñ and programming on the side
and after a few years there I started
this hackathon series called comedy hack
day where developers and engineers our
developers and comedians made stuff
together yeah yeah because I was I was
going to hackathons and realizing that
they were mostly presentation
competitions not really programming
competition what's an example of
something that so one of the
was called times fi and it was a Chrome
extension that would allow you to turn
any website usually a junk news website
like BuzzFeed into a site that looked
like the New York Times but it would
inject the article into it and then like
you could click the ads and it would
basically create a slideshow of all the
images yeah that was great and there are
there a ton of them um yeah so he did
that for like four years with a few of
my friends and I had gotten into cycling
when I was out here and I found this
thing this like world record that I
wanted to go for and I and I did it and
it worked out and people started
treating me differently and it was
really weird and I and I like started
feeling this like pending doom of my
youth and vitality fading away
it was a most elevation climbed in 48
hours oh wow
so is that well it mine was like 97
thousand feet got it yeah so so yeah so
people were treating me differently and
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna be
young forever and so I quit and I went
on like a five-month bike tour okay out
of the country and I went to Japan and
Vietnam and New Zealand and I came back
and I had no job and I had no idea what
I was gonna do and then Luke Iseman who
used to work here called me up and asked
me if I wanted to do a contract for the
blog and so that started you know three
years ago okay
oh okay so you start with the blog and
then so what were the steps into how you
eventually started this the YC podcast
and what why even the podcast yeah
so it should be said that Aaron did a YC
podcast a few years ago called startup
school radio and yeah I wanted actually
I didn't care as much about making a
podcast I wanted to make a youtube
channel because YouTube I think a lot of
people know now has great SEO and
podcasts of terrible SEO and so I was
like alright what's the easiest way for
us to create a ton of content for a
YouTube channel and then title it all in
a way that you know like our founders
get attention like stuff we want to talk
about gets attention and more
importantly it doesn't fade away and so
I was like well podcast is a good way to
do that
and yeah we just started from there oh
so podcast is the way to get the content
and then YouTube is the way to spread it
well because we do both but I I think it
was like 2014 or 2015 and I started
following Joe Rogan and I just saw this
like massive growth happening and people
were like clipping his videos and
creating like fan channels and now I
think his YouTube channel gets as many
views as his podcast gets downloads
right which isn't true for ours
right but yeah if you look for adore
Chun online like I'm sure Google
yourself yeah so to calibrate a list to
calibrate us a little bit so the why
Conor account how do you like how many
views do we get or you know how do you
how do you even calculate this or what
metric actually matters and so let's
talk about that yeah so the thing that
ultimately really matters is like we
kind of have two goals so one is to you
know help educate founders and people
who are in the startup game and two is
to bring other founders in so the way
we're trying to calculate this and it's
still pretty loose is by driving
applications and that's like the main
thing but in terms of like sheer metrics
you know we started out just like a
possibly a little bit bigger than other
shows by having like maybe two or three
thousand people automatically subscribe
and now we're maybe a 40-ish thousand
give or take you know five or ten
thousand every episode plus YouTube so
YouTube can go from like a thousand to a
hundred thousand depending on how the
person is yep
yeah so alright so I want to get into
how you create a podcast essentially and
your tips there so let's pretend I'm I
want to do a podcast and so I have a
topic that I want to do how do I decide
if that's actually a good idea or not to
even work on it do you have an idea in
mind um no I have a well I can come up
with a theoretical idea so one I've
always just joked around doing which I
think actually might be a good idea is
to do a podcast where I ask little kids
question like deeply philosophical
questions or I'm just because I think
they will they actually have a great
insight into the world in which we are
you've seen that show right can say the
darndest things yes people have told me
about that I have not seen it but I've
seen clips of it seem like little clips
yes yes so right off the bat there's
clearly an audience all ready for this
like that show worked the first question
is honestly do you want to do the thing
and I think another question that a lot
of people don't ask is am I willing to
even create like a time box around this
and say I'm okay
if I make 10 episodes because one of the
hardest parts about podcasting in
particular if it's not your job they
like with YC I'm just like okay we'll
just keep banging out every week if it's
not your job it can become a real grind
because those metrics don't go up that
quickly you know getting from like
30,000 to 40,000 40,000 50,000 can take
years for certain people so assuming
that you really want to do the thing
think what could I maybe make like eight
of these like Alexis Madrigal did that
with a container podcast I don't know if
you'd listen to that one it was super
cool and it's like the short version I
thought that was a great idea so then I
would would this be scripted in any way
probably not but I would have to
probably edit ah oh yeah okay so what I
would suggest doing that is just getting
like a basic basic setup and then just
going and recording a bunch like don't
even release got it cool and so the Y Z
podcast has every every pop every
episode has its own top topics so how do
you come up with those topics yeah so in
many ways it's about like stuff I'm
interested in I I don't know I I hit
this point where you know we hang out
other we you hang out with other people
I see in people who are in tech and I
just found that there wasn't really any
tech podcasts that interested me because
it all feels very inside baseball and
it's like maybe other founders aren't
interested in this either because they
talk about it all the time so I thought
okay
perhaps we could focus on technology as
a core as like a pillar but also do you
know art in science and in
entrepreneurship and then it's just been
like getting a mix of these people so
yeah I
a big driver is obviously if they have a
following but then yeah so you have a
topic for the episode then you obviously
need to find someone to interview
usually goes the other way okay
tell me yeah tell me the water
operations of how you put together a
whole target entire podcast so a common
one is I ask someone who I see like you
hey who do you want to do a podcast with
you know Kevin Hale has done a few
recently that's what that was there are
other ones for instance I did an episode
with John press Gill who's a quantum
physicist at Caltech and he suggested
other people so he was like oh man you
got to get like Scott Aaronson Leonard
Susskind all those people and so that's
a really common thing yeah it's just
finding trends finding things that are
interesting
going from there it is booking guests
easy hard or are there what are reasons
why people don't want to do cuz I'm sure
some people said uh not really
the more common know is now replying got
it yeah
but there are there are some fringe runs
for sure where people say I don't know
if I want to be on a YC podcast
interesting because there are certain
brand connotation interesting yeah okay
you're making this actually to do a
podcast sounds like almost like starting
a startup like you need to validate your
audience you know you there's a lot of
hard long days of work to do and you
know maybe there's a lot of cold
emailing cold outreach essentially and
just like keep asking people to do it
until they actually and then keep keep
learning to I think thinking about
content in the same way you think about
product is just like great they go you
can apply all the same ideas cool
alright so how do you prepare for
interviews in particular you have some
interviews that involve topics which
you're probably not an expert in like
physics these kind of things but you
actually ask really good questions so
yeah how do you do that so I I think I
would probably break apart the episode
types so there there's episodes like
office hours with the door okay I know
you I know the kinds of questions that
come in I don't really have to prep for
that one there's a middle level which is
a founder of a company like say Ryan P
Cineflex port I kind of know what flex
port does I've seen Ryan talk before in
that instance what I would do is find
every podcast he's ever done and listen
to all of them at like 2x speed so
you're like okay this is the stuff he's
excited about these are the anecdotes
he's used a million times avoid anything
that he's gonna like have these really
easy places to go and the last category
are the quantum physics type episodes
which ya to confirm your belief I'm not
an expert in yeah does it take like for
example that episode itself did you like
these some of these you don't have you
barely did you any prep just one like
that it'd take weeks or days or the
first quantum physics episode with well
there was a hard one before that too
with Rana Adhikari about gravitational
waves but the quantum one was more
difficult that probably took two and a
half days between listening to John's
talks and reading articles he's written
you know with with other people I'll
Scott Aaronson I read his whole book hmm
and you just like take notes on that
kind of thing but but ultimately the the
goal is actually not to become an expert
the goal is to become informed enough
that I know more than maybe the average
listener but not so informed that we
fill it with jargon and talk about stuff
that like no one really knows about or
cares about that makes sense yeah but
there are exempt like the Susskind
episode which is one of the most popular
ones we had planned for months and then
the week before I hadn't done any prep
yet the week before I'm like alright you
know we're gonna meet here that it added
up no reply but it usually when that
happens it means that he's ghosting me
huh and so I didn't do any prep and so
he I'm like alright he's ghosting me
he's ghosting me he's ghosting me we're
doing the interview on Monday he emails
me Sunday night and I'm like oh [ __ ]
chromatin so possibly the YouTube
comments reflect my level which is a
separate thing got it with was that the
most whoa what was the most challenging
one the I would say that hmm
so John Prescott was particularly
difficult because he's also very chill
and so keeping it upbeat keeping it
interesting keeping it fun
but I would say the one I bombed
Hardison was Jocko a Lincoln Mike
Cirelli
I don't know if you listen yeah I think
I was just too nervous I have this thing
where when I get nervous I laugh it was
fine you know like we hung out
afterwards and it's like yeah this is
much better
before ball so on the topic of keeping a
podcast or an episode engaging how do
you like you said some people are just
really chill and maybe they're montanus
or whatnot how do you push them to keep
it engaging so usually there's this it
doesn't come out in the podcast but we
talk before we start recording right and
so you kind of feed them what they
should think about how they should act
like you know basically like these are
the norms of the show and most of its
just about making them really
comfortable and we do a slight amount of
editing usually almost none but if I
edit anything it's often the first five
minutes I'll just cut the whole first
five minutes off because you're like oh
adora really got warmed up and she was
into it at this point yeah and I can mix
in an intro like people think this
matters but like the intro doesn't
really matter I think I don't know it's
not a big thing that I care about and
actually one of the best podcasters in
this regard is Russ Roberts from econ
Tom oh I love that one yeah yeah so if
you'll if you pay attention to his show
he always starts with a not a
controversial question but a question
that's not a softball and I think that's
a really great way to start the show got
it because you you want to give them
something that's interesting to them but
you don't want to confront them and this
is something that a lot of podcasts
hosts and I I fall prey to it too you
don't want to offend someone and so
you're really nice so you ask them all
these like softball questions but you
don't really go anywhere and that's what
that's how you end up with like the Joe
Rogan Elon Musk episode they're so bad
it's like Joe Rogan's great and Elon
Musk is capable of giving good answers
but because he knows so much more than
Rogen and Rogen didn't prep that much he
just dodged him the whole time and he
was fanboying yeah so yeah yeah those
get obvious after
the first 10 minutes it's like okay this
is going down though yeah not gonna
learn much here you listen to you listen
to full episodes normally rd children of
any event I guess I try if I'm going I
try listening to Joe Rogan I love I like
his so do I listen hold maybe once a
week I'll listen to me in other shows
you listen years those are maybe the
only two were a regular listen to the
whole thing
um yeah I guess not more because this is
something that I often think about
because of metrics not the metrics the
analytics are so bad you don't know like
man should I just be cutting this down
too yeah I think they're just different
on it's not like you to where you can
see where they just dropped off well you
have Apple analytics but they're not
very good
orally and it's only a percentage of
them are yeah yeah okay I want to talk
about analytics in a second shirt but
actually let's just talk about analytics
okay so Apple Analects there's nothing
like Mixpanel or amplitude ernie's it's
like google google analytics version
point one that's where I get you because
you I think what might not be obvious to
people some podcasts aren't like YouTube
videos you don't upload your podcasts
iTunes you upload your podcasts to a
host and then the host serves the
podcasts from an RSS feed and because
that's the way it works what information
you can get is like serves like it's
been downloaded basically X amount of
times but you don't have any kind of
that like retention data that you have
unless you're using Apple or you're
using an embedded player so if you
listen for instance on the YC blog in
the embed thing then I know but yeah so
really only these pod caplet podcast
players might know that well they will
know it given what that went for that
episode I guess that yes it's actually
played on their podcast yeah but I guess
the players have you're seeing
fragmentation amongst players now I've
heard something like sixty percent is
Apple a couple podcast okay got it so
it's pretty big share yep but then after
that is I think that there's a dominant
player on Android
I forget what's called and then the
cashbox on it's actually not that one I
always so I just well that was a YC
company and that was like when they
apply to us like no way the podcast app
there's the podcast it's like such a
great name you know yeah such a good
idea okay cool
so what are other tools that are
indispensable for the podcast so maybe
you would start with a software and then
you've got a lot of gear but I would I
say so I did my research and I listened
to before this I listened to you a lot
of your first episode no and so you can
heat and which is actually pretty good
quality but then if you listen to the
last ten episodes that you just did you
can hear the sound quality like there's
less echo you can hear the voice more
clear yeah so yeah maybe walk me through
like how what did you start with and
what's the gear that like what's the MVP
gear you need yeah yeah you know and
then what do you have today
the MVP gear is this this is your phone
I can record a podcast on your phone and
don't let your gear disqualify you from
doing it that's my main point but what I
started with back in the I did a podcast
before oh I see - oh it's called it was
great it was called salt of the earth
it's done and it was really funny and in
contrast though I see podcast because it
was in relation to tech entrepreneurs
getting so much attention my friend and
I were we went to college together and
we both grew up in New England and none
of our role models were tech
entrepreneurs they were like local
electricians and stuff and so we said
dude why isn't there a podcast with
these guys cuz and an ladies who are
often very funny and so we is like
really hard to find these people but
funny successful small business
entrepreneurs so so we did that and you
know we maxed out like two thousand
downloads an episode or something like
that but we had really simple gear and
so that was a zoom recorder so it has
like four inputs totally great and sure
mics that were like you know fifty bucks
each and the zoom recorder I don't know
it's like hundred bucks so they're also
USB there's this thing called the blue
Yeti which you can just plug into your
laptop and record
got it cool and then oh yeah and the
gear now yeah oh yeah Sona if you listen
to this on a podcast Craig
like when he does an episode he he
actually has a lot of stuff and one of
the things he does is he takes down our
walls these portable walls that are in
another room and he like drags them into
like a really small conference room so I
guess that's were sound but yeah and I
think it actually ends up looking better
too in a we're in a weird way but uh
yeah so okay so what happened there was
I realized after I started doing this
podcast in this room that this is not
the best room in the world to record a
podcast but actually office doesn't have
many great rooms for that because you
don't you definitely don't want a street
window right but it also needs to like
not being used all the time and so I was
basically left with like this room so
yeah so I have these like sound blocking
things to eliminate echo because my
voice was getting picked up on your
microphone and now it's a little bit you
still get it but it's a little bit less
because we don't do the headphones
you've probably seen that before yes
yeah I tried it and everyone freaked out
I hate headphones exactly yeah I used to
do when I was in college II at a radio
show really and I was like you just
you're hearing yourself yeah talking and
I was the one who like it was annoying
one and just you were that host no no no
I well it was like a talk show so it was
like I'm scabbing it was like old school
podcast I guess what was it about it was
just it was a we talked about news in
the school and just regular politics and
stuff like that I really hope this was
not recorded but yeah it was a local
college news station okay cool yeah yeah
that's hard this is a separate question
that someone asked that we should talk
about hearing your voice but yeah so now
we use these are shure sm7b
mics these are like 300 bucks the
biggest upgrade was the recorder which
was actually from a youtube comment this
is called a mix pre 6 sound devices to
make these sure mic sound good you need
a bunch of what they call clean gain and
our zoom recorder didn't really do that
this thing does that and then we record
on like Canon dia
so they're like you know let's not have
a box each okay so your suggestion step
one just use an iPhone
that's good quality anyway well I
wouldn't suggest iPhone as doing it I
kinda I was like you can conceivably do
it with an iPhone got it but what I
would suggest is if you're gonna move
around locations all the time and even
if you're not if you're gonna do the
interviews in person get a recorder like
a zoom h4n something like that get sure
mics sm58 whatever they're like sixty
bucks and XLR cable so the cables to
plug them in and you can take it
anywhere if you're gonna interview
people remotely get a USB mic like a
blue Yeti and then just and then do it
over Skype so yeah there's a I've used
it one time I forget now that I remember
what it's called
there's podcasting software where you
can record online okay but if you just
google it okay cool
alright and then how do you and then
what's the sorry this is really noob
questions but it's like so you record it
you're editing it's you software to edit
oh yeah so we definitely you suffer at
it there's free software called audacity
okay
again you can take the file from your
iPhone put it into audacity you're good
to go we use because we have video we
actually just edit the video and then
export the video audio to a podcast I
see and then if you've heard it before
but like I record a an intro thing great
yeah which is what I like but other
people like songs other people like
little clips from the show whatever yeah
cool and then you have to serve it and
we use back tracks for that alright so
you mentioned your voice do you think
your voice sounds awful when you listen
to it it well I mean you can't used to
it that's my answer
okay yeah because you have to cuz you're
the one editing to so you have to play
backup yeah okay
woah cuz they yeah my answer to this
question is actually like what how do
you feel about your voice I I generally
don't like it but it sounds different
than what I'm like when I'm hearing
myself I sound very different yeah then
when I hear it on our record
version is it lower higher yes just not
what I expected snippets low a little
bit lower I think okay
I think I don't know yeah it's tricky
because actually some people have
figured out ways to manipulate in like
post-production their voice to make it
sound closer to what it sounds like in
their head you know like I often think
about this I did an episode of another
podcast and it was base year then we
normally record on and I was like oh man
that sounds like more like my actual
voice yeah but uh yeah personally I
don't really like the NPR tone like you
know really like soft oh yeah I don't
really like it so I'm okay with it but
you get a my voice in my head is lower
but as soon as you start recording
yourself on video all the time you're
like oh man that's what I look like and
then you feel like way worse about that
yeah yeah okay cool so let's move to
what you've learned from the YC podcast
it's all sure okay so let's start off
with actually what what has been what's
been the best interview your favorite
interview so far um so my favorite
interview so the most popular one is
Leonard Susskind
so that's yeah that's the most popular
one but I've actually learned a lot from
different people
I really like the Michelle qu Oh
interview with Kat so that was about art
and technology she's awesome
then Ryan Peterson interview was great
one he's got this like cool like hustle
but not annoying yet vibe which I really
like the Rosalyn watts the psilocybin
the mushroom interviews yeah that was
like because I mean I had heard about it
but I didn't know it in that detail that
was awesome and then maybe some of the
ones with my friends have been really
fun cool it's like like my friend Matt
Hackett started this company with Casey
nystatin so I like that oh that was cool
yeah yeah all right and what's the most
surprising thing you've learned about
startups after joining YC and
interviewing so many founders like Ryan
yeah I mean this is definitely one that
you should answer to but I think like a
core part of it that wasn't obvious to
me from the outside what
is how important confidence is and how
big of it how big of a role it plays in
just doing the thing a lot of people
oftentimes when I I meet them in their
interest in about YC they make up these
things in their heads that disqualify
themselves from starting and a lot of
the successful founders don't do that
ever
and then they also have gotten into YC
or some other thing and they like have a
little bit of like kind of wind behind
them and so they have just like the
confidence to do the thing and I would
say that's like a learned trait and
that's a skill that you can develop and
a lot of people might not think it is
but I I really do think it is so yeah I
would just tell people like just do the
thing and like know that you're good
enough because they're just normal yeah
I don't know what do you say no I think
I think that's that's a good observation
I I think it's harder you know one of
the things as working with startups now
yet I do is during office hours for
example is is just keep the keep the
optimism of where this could go
at a realistic but high level meaning
like every day you know the ground every
day you would not think it's going
anywhere fast but so it's always I like
to remind people like this is where you
know you started this for for this
reason yeah and and this reason could be
bigger than what you even thought about
what you thought it could be but
regardless you know you should always
think about why you're doing something
that's that's a really good thing to
like bigger than you think it could be
this is a big a big it's a it's a core
thing in Silicon Valley that I get some
criticism and because you could say like
all right not everything is venture
fundable nor should it be sure but
there's another way to think about that
which is it's not as risky as you think
it is and it's actually often easier to
find people to work with if you're like
I'm just gonna build rockets now yeah
and you really stand out whereas like
doing these like I don't want to put it
down but like hackathon level like SAS
tools you
as compelling to people right no that's
been a big takeaway for me as well all
right so I'm just I'm gonna start going
through questions that our twitter has
Twitter was great I don't have to
prepare much for this interview so what
have you learned from any of your guests
that you've put into practice I mean I
think like on honest-to-god main thing
is it's just gotten me super anxious
about doing my own thing you must do a
start-up now or something yeah yeah
because you can only interview so many
people were like I mean this is this is
fun to do but you know being the host it
just it kind of sinks into your mind as
I mean kind of reviewing YC applications
to as this observer of trends happening
of things happening and you realize that
you're just like this passing moment in
someone else's life and it's cool and
everything but they're like getting
right back to their thing so I really
admire that that's been a big thing Sam
encouraged me to just like do the thing
which is like always good and he's very
helpful there mushroom interview very
interesting and you can do your own
research privately in different
countries if you want to do that Tim
Wong he he did the container book with
me oh that's right yeah and he's been on
twice he's the AI policy guy yeah okay
Tim's awesome and so Tim is one of the
only people I know who has been able to
maintain cool jobs but also have all the
like little side hustle projects going
on and his work ethic is unprecedented
in my mind for that kind of thing
and I think maybe the last one is just
realizing like it doesn't take that much
to generates it's a pretty real
following online by writing and
communicating clearly mmm I think like
YC that's at the core of YC right like
PJ's essays or content marketing I mean
they're cool they're obviously like
valuable but it's you know yeah and you
know like Andrew Cortina from venmo
that's how I found out about him
and even like Michael likes eyeballs
essays are great it really helped him
yeah so yeah I like them when they're to
the point yeah I mean this is tricky
right like that's just a style thing
yeah like who are your favorite writers
right now I guess in that in that scene
and the kind of sex scene I don't you
know you don't think this is a podcast
yeah I wish
PG would write more essays is what I I'm
secretly hinting at that anyway alright
so what are the what are the top or the
most counterintuitive or maybe
non-consensus things you've learned
about building successful startups after
interviewing so many founders I think
well okay I also I want your answer on
all of these really cool questions
there's definitely no one model for a
successful startup they're usually not
riding some trend in the middle of the
wave they're like wait early so it seems
weird they're not doing like AI
blockchain data right now that's
definitely a thing and and then I think
they like often are more focused on
finding these really big problems than
they are on just focusing on like doing
a start-up or a company and they're
definitely not attached to a solution a
lot of these people with that in mind
in my experience like there aren't a lot
of crazy pivots like 180 degree pivots
they come in and they're like hey I
found this thing and then all of a
sudden they realized that it's like
quite large or they change degree a
little bit you know but it's not like a
total turn yeah and then the last thing
is like they're just normal people you
know I think they get built up so much
yeah I agree with that
cool what's your answer oh I I agree
with that's a good question all right
you know I actually agree with the whole
what did you say about the AI blockchain
though thing oh they're they're not in
the like the middle of a big trendy wave
alright early okay so know what I was
thinking was I think the best ideas are
when you can explain the
problem and even the solution without
seeing jargon like without saying a are
blockchain yeah um so I think some
investors are when you say those words
they they're like I'm in but for me it's
I think if you can articulate it without
Africa actually describing the new tech
you're doing like that's never that's
always like the mechanism of which
you're solving the problem but that's
never you know I don't think that's the
problem you're solving if that makes
sense
I totally I mean it's it's this
questions like what more do you need man
it's a tools question right yeah but
it's not a product question and that's
the answer
like I said content product same thing
like do you make a good podcast you make
a good app or whatever you might be
making yep yeah okay so now that you've
done podcasting for many years if you
have to start one again from scratch
okay how would you structure it okay so
I have a couple notes on this but the
thing is I kind of did start this
podcast from scratch so in many ways it
reflects my personal taste and how I
like shows to go if I were to do my own
thing like not YC related from scratch
so that like the main constraint here
has been this is still my job right and
so that in that way I think in real life
I would have in real life in like a non
YC podcast I'd have more like really
strange people like weird like
definitely do not fit in this podcast
it's an example of that well he's not
okay so one one friend comes to mind
he's not actually weird not that weird
but he is an off-the-grid guy in the
middle of Vermont and so he's like built
his whole cabin in the woods he's
homeschooled all of his kids he is
solar-powered like all that stuff but
he's also you know yeah teacher out of
college and so he's super smart but a
sweetheart and like living this very
weird different life that I think
appeals to a lot of people so like stuff
like that we're just there have been
moments where Mike could I is this like
a YC episode and whatever maybe not I
mean even like the casein I said episode
I was a little
like I don't know if this is gonna fly
ah so there's like a little bit of a
branding thing you have to think about
is that what you're well well yeah I
mean this is like a separate
conversation but given that the podcast
has grown a little bit you know I have
like 18 bosses everyone who I see is
cool but like that like at any given
moment I can get emails from anyone yeah
and like this is how I feel about the
podcast and usually it's an expression
of personal tastes and this is something
that you have to get used to with
creative work right
it's like differentiating oh this is
objectively good feedback even if it
hurts versus oh they just have a
personal opinion it feels that they feel
that way and both strategies can work
mm-hmm which is really hard got it so
yeah so the answer the question is like
I would make it more weird I would have
like maybe like sillier people on but I
would definitely still do YouTube do
transcripts do the podcast like clip the
show as much as you can like I'm really
bad at that yeah but like clipping it
for YouTube yep and then like pro tips
big names still work yeah like trend
still where I don't do a lot of trans
stuff yeah big names work do you see
when you talk about clipping do you see
does that in whole unique wise unique
listener wise anyway get you more
listens than people just listening it
from the audio stream so what's tricky
oh yeah this is a learning we have two
YouTube channels subscribe we have three
of Y Combinator and Y Combinator clips
right because what happened was
initially I was like oh I'll just clip
the show because this is great it's
great for SEO right you title like you
know Jessica Livingston on finding a
co-founder rather than Jessica lives
Livingston with Sam Altman right right
and and then you can make like five
clips from one episode which is cool
but when I put out all like seven videos
on one day everyone freaked out on the
YouTube comments will you do it man like
you're clogging my feed this was like
okay fine I'll pay CAC lips channel the
problem there is like the clips channel
doesn't have that like flywheel effect
so in the long run you see this with Joe
Rogan like there are
in aggregate like his show clipped out
will do more than an individual episode
but but you need an audience before
right yeah which requires like yeah
bigger bigger names help in that way
great make sense yeah one question why
are more podcast not actually videos on
YouTube because people are dumb by
people you know it's it's more work
right and I think this is actually like
a fairly new revelation like some people
have been doing it for a while but I
don't think it's been as obvious to
people that you can even just like
upload a still image of you and then the
audio and that would be a thing yeah
yeah but it's interesting that you
actually thought in Reverse like I want
to start a YouTube channel because
that's where the audiences yeah and then
I podcasting is a excuse to get that
content yeah what's that smart the
question was I met with Michael in this
room when we were talking about it and
we were like where the youth is hanging
out and I was like man it's like a lot
of these other mediums are kind of feel
aging to me whereas YouTube's just gonna
be young yeah it'd still was young be a
while oh and then you guys started
Instagram yeah it does another thing
about it so thanks for my snapchat - we
didn't do snapchat I held out because
people were like oh you want to be like
the YC personality on no we adjusted for
that yeah yeah but we clipped the
podcast on YouTube on Instagram actually
does really well too is just takes work
right yeah yeah all right so what
patterns have you recognized in just
from your lips just from YC but when a
YC podcast and when episode gets popular
viral what are the reasons for that it's
like besides like big name yeah big
names like an easy one usually it's some
certain like cohort of influencers grab
it online and then it just goes like
this has been true and I won't go so far
as to say any of the episodes have gone
viral oh yeah okay definitely no but one
of the strategies for
the physics episodes was we want more
people to apply who are studying physics
and there aren't that many big names in
those communities
therefore if we get the biggest names in
those communities we can get them to at
least know about YC right and so what I
realized there it was like those
communities again not viral but as soon
as anything is shared within those
communities everyone shares it and so
you have like John Prescott will share
it but then like Sean Carroll will share
it and then you know like it's got
Aronson will share it it's like one two
three four five six and so yeah like
finding these like small but really
tightly networked communities works
really well mm-hmm it's almost like you
want guests that are maybe not within
startup tech itself but it kind of
adjacent just this is my personal
opinion yeah this is like how I differ
ya know and it makes sense cuz I'm like
okay I'm actually a really good example
of that is a mister money mustache do
you listen that one that was about
personal finance and like say okay so
this has been a crazy trend happening
the past maybe ten years about people
saving high high high percentages of
their income and quote retiring early
right so I think Pete that this guy
mister money mustache saved up like
something like 600 K and owned his house
outright and then he you know quote
retired at 30 and it's become he's
become like a figurehead in a cult cult
leader I mean yeah the episode is called
don't start a blog to start a cult and
this comes from one of his talks and put
people of YC we're like dude what are
you talking about like sorry and but if
it he has this like passionate following
of in large part software engineers
because they earn so much money it's
very easy to save 50 percent of your
income and so yeah I was like oh this is
tech adjacent this physic thing is tech
giant people like taking mushrooms
that's tech adjacent that was more of a
trend thing actually yeah but yeah yeah
all right so in terms of the future of
podcasting so it seems like it's taking
off now and one of the primary problems
I guess is it's hard to make money
yeah I mean it starts with it's hard to
measure but what one it's hard to make
money what do you think is the future of
podcast monetization I think there are a
few possible avenues I I tweeted this
out recently but the with the Spotify
gimlet and courier deal right it's
conceivable that a lot of these
podcasters get on contracts with big
companies like Spotify and are just paid
because for the majority of them like
they're not making more than a you know
a thousand bucks a month off of ads like
if you're not a big podcaster a lot of
them aren't making any money and they
actually don't care all that much about
having maximum distribution which is
different than Rogan because Rogan wants
to sell comedy shows
he's monetized his podcast this is why
comedians dominate podcasts like they
have a business plan right here this is
all marketing and their content super
interesting
so they've figured it out the people who
have had products on the side have
figured this out for a long time
I think we're gonna see a decrease in
CPM around podcast advertising mmm
because it's been like a racket hmm and
now it's I think it's really thinned out
like as in it was more lucrative than at
least Bennet is now I see it was higher
than it would have would it actually
performed because it was just made up
right so you're like hey MailChimp I
want 20 grand and they're like okay fine
that's it what goes so yeah and so I
think that'll be a trend I think we're
gonna see some kind of patreon model
work out in some way I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw more like tipping
happening that will probably be a new
app stuff like Himalaya and China for
sure yes tons of Education and one thing
that I've really been surprised that
that doesn't exist yet is super
expensive podcasts huh like like $10 in
episodes I like it so so you listen
hardcore history I have yes decades free
that could be 50 bucks an episode yeah
easily like you see this stuff like
master class happen like why is it
history right and then you're seeing
more I guess we pay for audiobooks yeah
so I guess there's you're saying there's
something in the middle between
audiobooks which we pay a lot for and
free podcasts
there's it like I I heard the staff last
year but I'm not sure was solely true
but last year or whenever it was quoted
the audiobook market was three billion
dollars in the same year the podcast
market advertising was three hundred
million dollars and then when I talk to
my friends like wait a second
there's this huge gap here because most
people are actually listening a podcast
not audiobooks so there has to be some
kind of thing in the middle
especially around educational content
where people will pay a lot of money to
have you and like teaching them
educating them because I think there
probably is like a definitively best
American history teacher and a
definitively best Mandarin teacher right
yep and you a thousand dollars a year
for their podcast or whatever the great
courses yeah yeah that seems like kind
of in that spectrum but it's like it's
like Internet 2.0 though I think there's
like a new like a bigger version know
what happens yeah yeah the Himalaya is
actually I think a breeze I know you
don't know about it you should check it
out I'm trying to get some Chinese yes
on it right now
oh really yeah it's like this big
complicated thing all right so do you
think pot okay so there are so many
podcasts out there yeah um do you think
it will become saturated like the music
in history or do you think the music
industry saturate no I thought that
question was like a false premise I
don't think music or he's like is
youtube saturated I don't think so hmm
is blogging saturated yeah I mean there
are a lot of there's a lot but that
doesn't mean like you know like you said
like PG doesn't write an essay a day for
you like yeah yeah and would that be
enough maybe not even yeah what do you
think is missing in the podcast world I
guess we talked about the educational
content yeah I mean there's like a lot
of missing stuff around monetization for
sure but I think in many ways it's like
gonna be about people committing like a
lot of people do it on the side or
they've already had a product right so I
think shifting that model to be like hey
this is valuable you should pay for it
I'm making really great content and that
might require some kind of like basic
income salary from Spotify so if I'm
like hey adore
you want to make kids say the darndest
things here's whatever 30 grand year and
that's enough for you to get really
motivated to make all this stuff because
oftentimes like you don't see it because
iTunes doesn't make it obvious but
iTunes has hundreds of thousands of dead
podcasts and they just like never get it
going enough to commit right after three
or four and then it just kind of yeah
doesn't go anywhere yeah and then you're
done yeah I mean you quit and so it's a
good idea so you so maybe
so what you're saying Spotify might do
the Netflix model of or well you would
hope is that the Netflix model of where
they commit you to certain number of
episodes and then you just go for it and
then if it does well you just reduce
look it's like think about it right so I
heard that Jerry Seinfeld signed a
hundred million dollar deal with Netflix
Wow for comedians and cars plus some
other stuff okay how much could net foot
or Spotify sign adora for probably less
than odd so you know you could imagine a
world where like they hire a hundred
podcasters at 30 grand a year they all
work from anywhere in the world and they
just make stuff that people are really
into right first bada 5 yeah because
like at 30 grand per person that's
actually not nearly as much you know as
like paying for all the I don't know
Lady gaga
royalties so yeah I could see that
happening in terms of podcasters so you
obviously you listen to lots of podcasts
what has been you talk a lot about Joe
Rogan but who else has been like the
most influential for you
I think Russ Roberts is great when I
started the YC podcast I had just heard
about Yukon talk he's been doing it for
a long ever I still don't know why that
shows not bigger yeah I think it's
pretty big but it could be bigger I
wanted to do a combination of econ talk
and Rogan where it's like interesting
people who are technical but it's also
fun because that you can talks it can be
a little dry sometimes I really like
those but I have a dude I have like this
whole list I wrote down a lot of shows
you listen to so another dead so there
are a ton of dead podcasts that are
still good there's one called 7th Avenue
projects so this is by this guy Robert
poly who lives
SF somewhere you're nearby SF it's
basically like an NPR science show and
the interviews are great they're like an
hour long it's got its got the NPR vibe
but if you can get past that it's cool
there's another podcast I listened to
called barbell medicine so have you ever
gotten into lifting weights at all not
really okay so I got into it last year
because I hurt my back and I was like
how do I fix this and people said well
you should lift cool so this is podcast
called barbell medicine and it's two
doctors who talk about medical research
as it relates to exercise oh and so they
like read a bunch of papers and say like
oh you know like creatine is good or
like this proteins like garbage and like
this type of exercise does nothing and
this is why you should train like you
know three sets of five versus something
else
surprisingly interesting dead authors
podcast you listen that one mmm this
one's also dead it's a PHA left
Thompkins bringing on comedians who
imitate dead authors and they have like
it's like an interview show they do it
in their voice - yeah but it's I mean
it's all goofily oftentimes you don't
really know who what their voice sounds
yeah but the bore has one with Nick
Kroll I was amazing if you want to check
it out Berkshire Hathaway so yah who got
the rights to the Berkshire Hathaway
board meeting or the nothing board
meeting the conference the shareholder
meeting Cheryl da that's a podcast oh
wow which is awesome
the nine club here into skateboarding
growing up nine Club is amazing okay
have you like a bunch of skateboarders
from back in the day
my buddy Spencer does one called
prepared that's about manufacturing I
did an episode on that and startup
school podcast by Seth Godin did you
hear that one
no same name yeah yeah that's from like
2012 okay it's actually really good
cool so alright that's my list of so
I'll check out all of this how did you
discover the dead podcast or an author
by yes I subscribe when it was so active
or I'm in like the debt because cuz I am
when I have a topic that I'm interested
in I'll go in search for it and then
that's how I discovered somebody's
podcast that
don't really exist in him yeah so what
like what ones are you into that are
dead well I'm not into it I just listen
to the one episode yeah I don't actually
have you checked out um listen notes yes
notes it's awesome yeah because that you
can index everything yeah yeah that's a
big thing but I mean it should be said
Discovery's totally broken yes which is
why the clipping this is this is what I
think will happen like there will be
some version of a podcast app that
resembles YouTube clipping that's a
podcast app and so what happens with
YouTube clipping is you just get in this
like five to ten minute clip one after
the next after the next term and like
Himalaya is much more like that right
then the standard models yeah yeah more
Twitter questions
okay these are this is these these are
trying to get unrelated but we'll just
finish off with some unrelated ones
what podcasts you listen to I why should
you
you have been YC wanderer I deal with an
econ talk listener Tyler Cohen Cohen has
yeah has a good one I listened to Rico
decode okay that one that once why do
you listen to podcasts what well I I
will preface with I actually listen to
audiobooks much more oh okay and so when
I'm kind of tired of listening to the
audiobook I will either switch to music
or podcast
okay and so it's kind of my other thing
that I listen to you but are you kind of
tuned out when you're listening you're
like doing something else
no I if I'm doing something else I'll
listen to music okay but I never
listened like it's hard to listen to
audiobooks especially but also podcasts
we enter tuned out but tech ones are
actually because it's like you know it's
not isn't it yeah I guess I'm not
learning anything entirely new and so
you can just listen it too while you're
doing something else yeah so that's what
I do okay yeah I'm similar yeah Patrick
bender asks what idea do you believe in
that your social group would think is
crazy oh yeah okay so this is why I'm
glad we got this question before hands a
moment to think about
I think cushy Internet jobs are bad for
innovation
okay like what's an example of that any
bank job where you just like show up and
kind of do work got it
and for that reason I think jobs should
have term limits on them unless you're
like the founder basically reverse
vesting yeah so it's like hey adora
you've been a partner at YC for five
years yes see you later yep and you yeah
and it's kind of implied that like you
know if you go join Sequoia or something
you're like okay fine
yeah because I've it's related to this
early retirement thing but I see a lot
of people like maximizing that and just
staying on at big companies and it makes
me mad because they have so much talent
and they like they have safety nets they
could go do stuff so mmm interesting I
think maybe somewhat related to that I
think there should be forced sabbaticals
totally all right after you work for so
many years you should take time off to
like just do something else too I get
that because I think if you work at a
company especially if it's like just one
position in on one team you just kind of
get stuck and you Beck you know that
creativity flow and yeah just thinking
outside the box gets a little bit harder
after some time I've been surprised that
that's not like a bigger employee
retention thing yeah I know some
companies do it but it's after like
quite a while yeah how so cat did one
last year yes cat who's also a YC
partner yeah yeah and she came back
because she had all these thoughts right
and then she came back and and she was
like super excited and really happy and
I was like you know what I kind of
didn't feel like doing anything and that
was okay too yeah I got off my phone and
to her point that's totally fair yeah
but I do feel like that the four
sabbatical would need to be longer than
the company oh no yes I haven't thought
about how long it should be at least six
months
yeah three six month three months 36
months I think it's such a good idea
yes but like if there is an even greater
incentive for them
so basically what I'm saying is like I
want people to leave their jobs but like
if they were like you know we will
decrease your salary if you return or
like we'll give you some seed funding or
something but then you see this stuff
happening at Google right where they're
like funding internal startup be things
and it just feels like employee
retention right yeah I don't know yeah I
don't thought through the right
mechanism for that is but what cuz I'm
curious about you like if you two and a
half rear I'm sorry okay yeah we started
roughly the same time yeah yeah yeah
like how much time do you think you
would want to like really consider yeah
that's yeah thirty six months is
probably I think because then I think it
lets you just focus on other things that
again will help you with your job
actually yeah
and anyway but but yeah this is the
thing like a lot of people don't know
this about you oh I see but you've
jumped around between a bunch of stuff
with in YC within the agency that's
right where is like some other people
happen right right and so you're kind of
like always looking for it right for
news my version of a DD yeah and is that
also in the back of your head like maybe
I want to start a city or maybe I want
to do this on my own
yeah I will see I I and back my head as
always what's the next startup sure yeah
so that's always in it and I think we
talked about the neuro in our episode
probably maybe whatever the case you
know it's on one hand being at YC is
great cuz you you you're with all these
founders and you're motivated about
startups in general and there's so many
ideas on the other hand it's like one
one week I'm I'm obsessed with this one
idea and then I talked to another
founder then I just like ping pong
around ideas and so it's very hard to
stay focused it's tricky right cuz you I
can see it going both ways because I
with all this stuff like it's all good
there's no like objective right answer
but yeah I can see that that
intellectual like game being really
compelling yes but then your addictive -
totally but you're also like a maker
right yeah and so is that that that yes
50 might happen
yeah watching people build and you're on
the sideline not bill
is really rough so you have to come up
with at least hobbies side projects that
often go uncompleted unfortunately all
right so Zachary cannon asks oh okay so
so this is one of the application
questions oh yeah please tell us about
the time you most successfully hacked
some non computer system to your
advantage so I kind of mulled over this
one for a while and I think that the
silly world record actually might be the
best one because it had like the largest
outcome so basically what happened was
there was this trend in cycling whatever
I did is like four years ago where
people were climbing the height of
Everest on their bike and they called it
everything and I was like I could
probably do that meanwhile I'm not I
mean I'm heavier now than I was then but
even then I was like 170 pounds which in
cycling is like heavy like you are
you're the fattest cyclist if you're 70
what's the typical weight I mean the
guys who win are like 135 140 and
they're taller than me so they're
stronger than hate they all look very
tall and skinny they look like skeleton
yes yeah so like you you're looking at
probably like five eleven hundred and
seven 137 pounds something like that and
they're stronger than me yeah and so I'm
like 170 pounds and yeah not not that
skinny so yeah so basically what I did
was like I did that ever sting thing and
it worked and I was like oh I could do
more of this
and so then I created a spreadsheet of
all the hills in the East Bay where I
could like maximize how much elevation I
could get in like the shortest distance
while also being like close to a
bathroom close also like not having
enough trout or not having too much
traffic like something that my friends
could get to so they could like help me
out and yeah through that spreadsheet
I like unlock this place that just
worked for me and so that's basically
how it happened oh wow yeah that's
pretty cool it was pretty cool you you
achieved Tirol issues my goal everything
exactly and then my life was over
kind of quarter life crisis yeah yeah
basically and then havoc left the
country
all right um cool so last question what
see you obviously talked a lot of
founders and being at yce simul it's
myself um do you ever feel the pressure
to just go start a company and if you're
going to start a company what would what
would the problem be be that you're for
this one for yourself uh answer first
then the answer is yes I do feel yeah oh
yeah answer that's a leading question
totally yes yeah that's another thing
that's not really talked about much of
the podcast or in public at all but
working at YC and managing YC is a weird
kind of like cat wrangling where like
the default personality type is like
solo founder kind of vibe and like they
everyone just wants to be doing their
own thing all the time you know it's
like boxing people in it's good you got
a bunch of CEOs basically with very
different styles which is actually kind
of interesting like it hasn't been
selected for like one vibe yeah anyway I
think the answer is definitely yes and
where I'm kind of focusing right now is
I'm I'm getting this impression that
like people want freer lives and I think
you see this with early retirement but I
also think you see it on the other side
with like basic income and then I think
you see it in the middle with like Marie
Kondo and so there's like there's just
this vibe that people want like
potentially less stuff potentially
simpler lives potentially like more
freedom and so I think I would probably
develop a product in that space around
one of the things that's like most
expensive so like probably a housing
thing where it's like a ton of your
income goes into this but it's like this
aspirational thing that leads you to
leaving to leaving it for your life mmm
interesting yeah so it would be uh okay
I think I understand well I mean I mean
like I'm a little vague because I think
I might end up doing it yeah all right
anything about you there's a there's
tons of adora knowledge
it hasn't been on the pot I've you've
only done it like twice right yeah I
think I've done it twice three times I
did it once talking about startup school
and then once random questions from the
internet yeah right
yeah I probably should do more podcasts
or writing or something yeah if you want
so what what's your like what attracts
you as an idea right now or like a
market I don't know that's a question
there are a bunch of things I think
anything related to making life in a
city better anything from starting new
cities to just mobility and housing and
stuff like that I'm interested in
so we're funding more of those things at
YC it's cool I'm very on the other polar
opposite so it's kind of ironic I'm also
interested in this is remote
collaboration and remote work stuff yeah
and trying to figure out what are the
tools that can help kind of replicate
the you know I think a lot of like slack
in video and stuff like that that's all
that's all well and good but the thing
that you you still won't get is the
serendipitous yeah nature of living in a
city and is that possible when you're
not you know actually physically
together and I think if we can get if we
built something that get there then you
know maybe cities aren't as needed but
yep anyway that would that would go in
the face of 2,000 years of you know of
why cities are great why it Spurs
innovation and if an alien showed up it
would be Oh humans build these things
that's like our one goal yeah so those
are two topics come on I'm started
looking to brain computers and stuff
like that oh you're a link type stuff
yeah yeah stuff like that really but but
yeah I'm just I'm just starting is there
anything cool happening right now
like anything working I'm such a I'm a
beginner totally new how yeah oh yeah
but what else yeah and then a lot of
stuff in emerging markets there's just a
lot of
good engineers that are start like good
engineering talent that's popping up and
not like obviously India and China are
the obvious ones but places like Jakarta
we have a company in Iraq this this this
batch and so they're just building a lot
of basic I mean it's probably to us in
America it's kind of basic in
infrastructure stuff okay but I think
it's what's gonna spur innovation and
inspiron imme of a lot of these places
was that we decided yeah I mean I think
it's cool like obviously there's a lot
of arbitrage stuff people can do with so
much engineering talent but like would
you build home joy in Iraq like would
you be excited to do a thing again if
you I don't think that would work there
but yeah I've pretty much decided I I
don't think I want to work like the next
company I build is not going to be in
the o2o space like heavy operations it's
like it's it's gonna be more in software
and stuff like that yeah but but I don't
know it depends like I want to work on a
really good problem though first and
foremost and how I go about solving it
it's whatever so it ends up being that
then it ends up being that
so when why doesn't first go to that and
also I'm I think it requires local
talent to get that stuff right and so
I'm more interested in the position I'm
now which is helping them yeah do you
think like start things and think about
how to go about you know setting up
operations and and how to think about
metrics and stuff like that and getting
off the ground yeah but yeah so I I
prefer to work on that level in emerging
markets but it's fascinating to me so
what do you like
when is an opportunity gonna be good
enough for you to feel that it's right I
think what is it I mean I think on two
levels one is people you work with and
so finding the right team to work with
again and then to the problem again it's
something that where I don't get
distracted from so it has to be really
compelling to me right like if I can
come up with this
while I'm at well I see that'd be
amazing because I get distracted very
often yeah with new cool ideas yeah
and so yeah I think those are two okay
for me yeah I I want for you a lot of
things yeah I'm just like I'm not gonna
go full like Luke Iseman and like
screaming you should quit your job but
it's it's always the thing like it's
something I care about
yes so yeah all right well that has been
a fun long podcast thank you very much
thank you were doing this and I hope
others have learned okay thanks all
right
you